si le système décide de s'effondrer,
ce que je ne pense pas qu'il doive
d'ailleurs, je crois que nous pouvons créer une
transition juste vers les énergies renouvelables où la
vie peut continuer car elle n'est que saine,
mais devrait-il s'effondrer avant que nous
ayons le bon sens  pour ce faire, nous savons
comment survivre, nous les peuples autochtones et
et nous l'avons fait avant et avant
tout au long de la création, vous savez, mon fils, ma
fille, sait comment faire un feu,
comment chasser, comment pêcher, où est l'eau,
où sont les baies.  les
champignons sont là où vivent les pommes de terre sauvages
comment capturer le miel des
abeilles même si nous nous lapidons parce
que c'est leur territoire nous avons des moyens de
passer à autre chose et nous espérons
que cela n'en arrivera pas là  et cela
ne signifie pas - nous pouvons ensemble nous lever
et faire une différence
[Musique]
les peuples autochtones portent un
fardeau excessif de l'industrie extractive sur
leurs terres et volent à notre mère
la terre au Canada le goudron  sables ar  e un
exemple de ce qui se passe lorsque vous allez à
l'extraction d'énergie extrême et que vous
élevez du bitume qui va
créer une bombe à carbone une fois qu'il atteindra le
marché libre et sera libéré et cela
provoquera une augmentation de la température dans mon
jardin tue des poissons  cinq d'entre eux au cours des
dernières années dans la rivière Salt Fork
qui traverse notre communauté directement
liés à la fracturation hydraulique et directement liés
aux tremblements de terre des puits d'injection par les
dizaines de tornades qui sont énormes Je pourrais
vous donner un exemple après l'autre
[Musique]
nous avons  vu que l'
espoir du parcours de surf des ancêtres est vivant si l'on
considère la dévastation que nous avons
vécue avec le processus génocidaire avec lequel
nous avons vécu, il ne reste que les
plus forts d'entre nous, donc nous survivrons,
nous le savons mais je crois que c'est en
place  à vous et à toutes les autres personnes pour dire que
nous devons arrêter ce qui se passe en
Amazonie dans cette forêt vivante en ce moment
aujourd'hui, pas demain, nous devons mettre les gens
en position d'élection ou de
révolte et de s  oui, nous exigeons que les choses
changent ici sur terre pendant que nous en avons la
possibilité, sinon nous négligeons notre
devoir en tant que personnes en tant qu'humains dans le cadre d'un
cycle de vie, il y a donc toujours de l'espoir, mais il
faut agir pour faire de cet espoir une
réalité
[Musique  ]
Je pense que je dirais la même chose à
n'importe qui partout où nous vivons selon une
philosophie de septième génération que
laissez-vous aux générations à venir
quel est votre héritage est-ce la
salle dorée de la tour Trump
qu'est-ce que vos enfants vont manger ça
robinet d'or ou voulez-vous que vos
arrière-arrière-arrière-petits-enfants aient de l'
air pour respirer de l'eau pour boire et une
terre pour les aimer
[Musique]
toi